we're going to begin with this though
president biden's tough tone on the
covet crisis he has had enough in a
sharply worded speech yesterday mr biden
says vaccine or regular testings will
now be required for any company with
more than 100 employees
the president spoke directly to the 80
million americans who are still
unvaccinated saying his patience is
wearing very thin
the deaths are rising sharply in this
country from the coronavirus more than
10 000 americans have died in the last
seven days alone
nearly all the victims are unvaccinated
people nancy cordes is at the white
house with the details of the
president's plan nancy good morning to
you boy the president pulled no punches
yesterday
right and big changes are in store gail
good morning this new order will force
millions of federal workers and
contractors to get vaccinated with no
option for regular testing instead also
today fines will be doubled for anyone
who is traveling by air if they don't
wear their masks but the real
centerpiece here is this sweeping new
rule for businesses that employ about a
third of the entire u.s workforce
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us with
millions of americans still unvaccinated
president biden is taking his toughest
stance yet now every company with more
than 100 employees will have to require
workers to either get vaccinated or get
tested weekly some of the biggest
companies are already requiring this
united airlines
disney
tyson's food
and even fox news businesses that don't
comply could face a 14 thousand dollar
fine per violation the same goes for any
medical facility that gets reimbursed by
medicare and medicaid if you're seeking
care
at a health facility you should be able
to know
that the people treating you are
vaccinated simple since this summer when
the president declared independence from
the virus it no longer controls our
lives cases have skyrocketed from about
twelve thousand per day to more than one
hundred thousand but some unions are
already bulking at the new mandates one
saying the government should trust its
employees to make their own medical
decision under consultation with their
doctor some republican governors and
lawmakers called the president's move
unconstitutional and the republican
national committee is already vowing to
sue crimes against humanity meanwhile
los angeles county the nation's second
largest school district voted thursday
to mandate vaccines for students age 12
and up
biden had his harshest words yet
thursday for republican governors in
states like florida and texas who have
tried to block mass mandates in schools
these governors won't help us beat the
pandemic
i'll use my power as president to get
them out of the way
the president also announced that the
federal government is going to be
spending billions of dollars to make
rapid tests more readily available and
cheaper and he'll be talking about
safety in the classroom once again today
when he visits a local school here in
washington d.c with the secretary of
education and the first lady nate
as the cases rise so should our
awareness on what is going on with covet
thank you nancy so much the